Hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to through the woods, now
this is just a demo of an upcoming
horror game that made specifically for
Pax East 2016, and I was at Pax East 2016
and I had not heard of the game so I
Didn't even know that there was a demo
available until just now, so, with this
Game we're gonna find out, can I, uh, uh, whoa
Woah, what did I do? What the hell did I
just- whoa, oh god, oh geez
Oh geez Scoob, whoa. (laughs) Holy shit, what did I do?
I'm just trying to play the game man, I'm just
trying to play the game
Oh man, I think um, maybe controller?
Oh, okay, ah
Woman: When I saw his jacket there on the ground, It felt like something inside me broke.
I suddenly realized that this is really
happening.
He'd been taken from me. I was his mother,
I was supposed to protect him.
He trusted me and I let him down as I
had so many times before. I promised
myself I would find him and bring him back.
I just hoped that was a promise I could
keep.
Mark: Me too lady.
Mark: So this lady lost her son and we got to
go 'through the woods' to get him back,
Which is kind of a common theme in
horror games, not that I'm knocking this
Game I don't want to make any criticisms
about this game especially just the
Early in the game, but i do say that this
game looks good and that is offen a
Qualification for a game being good- er,
that's not often a qualification for a
Game being good, I want to be very
specific- oh, hi! Why is the moon all 'splode?
Who sploded the moon??
Why is that? That's cool, but why?
See this is what I like, that's an
environmental clue
That's, that's something that's world
building that's just there and it's not
Explained but a lot of assumptions can
be based on that and that makes me
Thinks there's aliens involved in this
I don't know why or maybe it's some
distorted version of Earth
I like that a lot
Can I run? That's the flash light, oh
okay here we go
Running, where am I going- whoa what the hell
is that?
Who built a fortress out here? Who built
a Skyrim ass fort
Whoa, hey, wh- this is very
Skyrim
Wait a minute here, hello. How it do?
What is that? Myrkstad, oh man that's
weird- and cool! But weird
Why is that there? Why is these here?
What is all this? Oh my god it's totally
Skyrim! -I'm not wrong in that, everyone's
Getting the vibes right?
Holy shit, so what is, what is all this
doing here?
I mean obv- oh, I didn't think that could open
Hello, hi, anybody home? Oo, that looks like a
comfortable bed, oh is this my room?
Am I gonna be staying the night here?
Ok, whoa, it's a Nordic helmet! Ok, so maybe
the reason that I'm thinking that it's
Skyrim is because this is all based on
Like uh, Nordic ancient architecture and
stuff like that and- and it's just
Seemingly in the same place, because
that's what Skyrim was, it was like the
The North (Woman:Hello?) belongs to the Nords but you
know, all that
Northern culture, ye old Viking lands of old
Hello-
Woman: Place looks abandoned.
Mark: Yeah no joke it looks ancient, why else would it be abandoned?
And you're coming in with a, with a flashlight
and there's like medieval Helms that are
Rusted and old, but who lit these? What's
on the table?
X? Ok, text? "A bit further on he found a
crooked ram's horn, and soon he found the other
"Look at what I found boys!" He shouted, "What
did you find now then?" said his brothers.
"Two ram's horns," answered Askeladden.
"Throw them away! What are you doing with
them they?" They said contemptuously. "No, I have
things to do and these will do,"
Said Askeladden."
I don't want to know what you're going
to do with those ram horns,  and I don't
know why that's important for what i'm
doing here
Whoa, what was that? Oh, here we go.
The controls are only slightly wonky
I have to admit. It might be-
man I-, can you play with a mouse and keyboard?
Hang on, let me see
Oh you can! Oh why was I having trouble- oh this is going to be much easier than
What i was doing before, ok, man I kind of
got sidetracked from everything because
I was so interested in
The, like, environment, which is a good
thing! I got to admit, in a horror game
The environment is very important to, uh,
building the world like, like the thing
With the moon a horror game is like
emphasized on what goes around in the
World- hello?
"The old bastard came to the village
yestereve. The Craven whoreson took
Jorn's boy away.
The bastard! No one saw him come, though we set a watch some weeks ago. The boy didn't
Make a sound, the wretched thing! We'd all
a mind to go up there at last and put an end to this, but for the gates-
The cursed gates won't open to
those such as us. All's we can do is bide
And hope Jorn's boy was the last. The
corruption of the man! His heart, if he
Has one, must be rotted as a month-dead
swine. And our gods do nothing. A curse
On the whole festering pile of them. And
curse on the murdering bastard
Erik!"
Mark: Ok! So, so- ah shit, so why is Erik just given
free rein
And why are you bothered by some un-opening gates?
This is very weird. I'm interested, but I'm very confused- *screeching noise*
Hi-
Okay, ah, is that the month old dead swine I
was hearing so much about?
Okay, I'll go in, fine
I ain't afraid- Oh, shit balls. Hey- Who's there?
Oh- hey, hi! Can you open up for me?
Ohhh, it opened up for me, whoa
Okay
Who's doing that???
Okay, fine, fuck you.
*door closes* Son of a bitch
Woman: Hello? Mark: Hello, yeah, just call hello
After the doors mysteriously open and
then you wander inside and still hear
Footsteps outside the doors
Ok, hi, ok.
What's happening?
Alrighty then.
Should I go up there? Maybe.
Man, I don't like how narrow uh, the view is
I know it's supposed to be over the
Shoulder perspective and sometimes
that's good for games, but it's just
Combined with the slightly wonky
controls, it's just a little disorienting
Here
All right. Text: Erik told us tonight of the
pact and wore long ago.'Tis said ye
Could hear the terror of Ragnarok all
around, even as our people were brought
Here to safety.
The earth shook, huge structures of
Asgard fell from the sky over the
Mountain we now call Vargfjeld.
Fenrir killed Odin. Laid waste to nearly
all the worlds. Only we on Hoddmimis
Holt remained. Mark: Well, I- I don't know how true
that is considering the world seem to
Have progressed since the days of old.
But I'm not sure.. What do i know? I'm just a
mother looking for her son.
*door creak*
Hello? Hi? Oh- hi, how you doing?
How you doing? Dead in your bed I
see, asleep on the job, well I won't tell
Your boss
Like I said i-it's just really disorien'-,  disorientating-, disorienting based on how
Close it is sometimes to this- Woman: God dammit, who's there?! (Mark: God Dammit!) Where's
My son! Mark: Yeah, where's my son, can you tell me?
I-I seem to have lost him! So, somewhere
around here there's a mystery to be
Solved, but I don't know why my boy was
taken here unless it's the same person
That was taking children from long long
ago, and I don't even know how i was able
To track them back to this place, and I
don't even know why this place was lost
To the ages.
If Odin really is dead there's no hope
for the rest of us, we mere mortals
Oh shit, I swear I hear footsteps behind me
Alright whatever, What is this big rock thing? Is this important?
It looks kind of, maybe a little bit
important- oh man, is that recent?
Ugh, decapitated cow head?
Something along those lines? Ok, I guess I'll follow
the obvious trail *monster yell*
Well alright then, good thing I wasn't
able to properly face that whatever that
Was!
Okay bye, we're gonna go in here now, I'm
gonna go through the slightly ajar door
Oo, this looks good, am I finally gonna go through the woods?
Eh, alrighty then.
Well bring it on you bitch bastard, i'm
on the way to kick your ass to get my
Son back.
I'm a mom on a mission, and you ain't
gonna stop me
Maybe, maybe, you will stop me, oh it's the
blasted moon again!
Good job, alright
Okay, ah, good, I was wondering when the
creeping bass section was gonna start.
Good, lightning on a clear sky!
That's reassuring, I'm sure that doesn't
bode ill will for me and death is not on
The horizon.
Fuck you, hello, hi!
Weird ancient magical Nordic symbols of Myrkstad!
I-I can't interact with you so I don't
exactly know what that's going to be
doing unless that's like some weird ethereal checkpoint system. Which it very
Well could be, I'm not 100% sure.
Hello, ah yes, the deep thumping rumbles. Setting the- *monster starts moaning*
Who be moanin'? I don't remember allowing
anybody to be moaning in my vicinity
Ugh
That's a lot of moaning! That's a bit more moaning than I signed up for
I just signed up for maybe moderate
amounts of moaning- whoa, is that a thing?
What the fuck is that?! Whoa, what the fuck is that?! Ah! It's a troll!
What am I supposed to do about that?! *Maybe run?* Uh oh, I'm fucked
I'm fuber nucked, what am I supposed to do about you?!  Fuck you! Oh geez *mark dies, of course*
*sounds of death*
Okay.. Ah, good, it was uh, it was uh, it was a
checkpoint system and that was a troll
And i'm assuming I was supposed to run
past that very expeditiously
Ohhh it's much easier to see without the
flashlight enabled
Oh, that's cool actually, ok, so that's
actually a good thing because i don't
Necessarily need the flashlight right
now I only need it when I'm able to look
For things and that's actually good
because the flashlight was casting harsh
shadows anyway and making it very
difficult to see.
Ah, so I need to creep, ah, is that what I need to do?
Where's Mr. Moany, huh? Where's Sir Moans-A-Lot?
Is he not there? *Troll moans again* Oh, I hear him. I hear the moany bitch over yonder way. But I'm not gonna
Turn on my flesh light, not my flesh light,
my flashlight
Oh, I think he spotted me, well fucking
shit balls I'm out of here bitch! *Troll starts screeching, upset Mark senpai is leaving him*
Ahh! Don't moan on me! Don't moan me! Don't moan me bro!
Uh, ah, fuck you, ah! Oh fuck off! *Creature moans continuously*
*yeah, it's still moaning and gasping for breath...*
Man, I gotta commend that guy's moaning ability
He's just non stop moaning mister, oh geez, he's the moan master
Oh, god,  he's the troll moan master. Good god,
stop it man
There's no need for moans and groans
this deep into the woods
Okay that's probably not a way to go, low
flashlight probably'll help over here
Alright, so where the hell are we going now?
And also why in modern society in the
days of flashlight and stuff are there
Still
Trolls and stuff in the woods? That
doesn't seem very normal
But then again a lot of things in these
types of games aren't exactly normal.
Hello, uh oh, well that's not good.
Woman: When I saw his jacket there on the ground,
I felt like something inside me broke. I
suddenly realized that this is really
Happening.
He'd been taken from me, his coat, his
little coat, lying in that dark place. I was
his mother I was supposed to protect him.
He trusted me and I let him down as I
had so many times before. His jacket was
A symbol of my failure.
I promised myself I would find him and
bring him back.
I just hoped that was a promise I could keep. Mark: Oh, OH NO, NOT THERE!
Don't do that! Oh, I just got done with
Mr. Moany!
Oh, man, Moody Moany was moaning up a storm
in mopey moaning, moaning woods
Oh man, call this game through the moans! Ah,
fuck man. I-I know it's a demo, but I just
Got into it! I was just figuring it out.
Oh, man, so that's the end of the demo of
through the woods, the full game is gonna
Come out some point in the future but
man, this has a lot of potential.
I love the world building, that's what I
really love, I really do love the
World building and I kinda am now
connecting the dots between this is
Assuming that the, uh, the Nordic mythology
is real and I'm assuming what they mean
By the pieces of Asgard falling apart is
the moon exploding but somehow life
Still continued and man, there's still
trolls and monsters in the woods so this
Could be very good and I'm looking
forward to this and seeing the full game
Come out I just don't know when that's
gonna be,
So thank you everybody so much for
watching, and as always, I will see
You, in the next video, bye bye!